with direct access to players managers
and even
royalty for four years greg clark has
held the top job in english football
it took less than an hour to talk his
way out of it
if i look at what happens to high
profile female footballers
high-profile colored footballers and the
abuse they take
on social media i think i heard you
referred to
colored people earlier on isn't
if if that's the case would you want to
withdraw that language because isn't
that exactly the sort of language
that means that inclusion is not a
reality if you if you please allow me to
respond
one if i said it i deeply apologize for
it secondly
i am a product of having worked overseas
i worked in the usa for many years
where i was required to use the term
people of color but it wasn't just that
clark's appearance before mps
was a slow-motion car crash he also
suggested that being gay was a life
choice and that girls don't like the
ball kicked at them hard
england's young star tyrone mings was
involved in drafting an fa
code to improve diversity in football
revealed only last month
we all have a duty of here to understand
what terminology you can and can't use
and if you fall foul of that or there's
a slip of the tongue
the man enough and brave enough to to
apologize for it
in 2017 during the dispute between
england footballer annie aluko and coach
mark sampson
clark described institutional racism as
a bit of fluff
some were surprised he held on to his
job then he's paid the ultimate price
for
the language and the lazy terminologies
that he continues to use
and sometimes sorry is not enough
and it's happened on this occasion the
fa board in the past has been called
male pale and stale as an organization
that's been accused of being full
of dinosaurs but times are changing
and that's why greg clark was gone so
quickly
now the fa must show that it was a
problem with an individual
rather than an institution
greg clarke released a statement saying
my unacceptable words in front of
parliament were a disservice to our game
and to those who watch play referee and
administer it
this has crystallized my resolve to move
on
the fa search for his successor has now
assumed even
greater importance a reminder that
football
is still tackling ignorance arrogance
and discrimination
from the terraces to the boardroom